you know that's true Joe and Phil I'm
glad that you're here
cool thanks man I'm glad we're not
talking about incest because you are
dealing with Jim and I are queers no not
both we uh well you know Jim's a
comedian we're both radio show hosts but
what you might not know is as of Sunday
night we are bar experts or experts
experts at bars really did you know that
I had no I know this is all news to me
now I've never drank really and I gained
weight when I was 18 right right also
I'm picky about what I eat yeah Jim
really only likes fancy restaurants yeah
I'm a gentleman fine tastes right same
however we became bar experts because
Jon Taffer called us and he said Johnny
from Barbara yeah I love Jon Taffer and
he said hey Jim Norton and Sam Roberts I
want you guys to be the secret spies on
bar on Annapolis in a bar rap he's a man
of his word we had interviewed him a lot
and we had me in LA I think he promised
that he goes I'm gonna get you guys on
and yeah and the to us off mic I would
love the show yeah I love the show yeah
he did it and it happened he said come
out to Florida to temple really Tampa
we're flying you out we want you to be
like the secret guys that go into this
bar free cheating free trip to Tampa but
won't you get what if I you recognize
what if you walk in it's okay oh yeah
there was a great danger it's okay Jim
actually was recognized uh-huh and
because we were all so unlike Mike how
to show that morning it's okay because
it's okay for people to know that you're
in town and just going to the bar they
just can't know oh you're part of the
show they know can all the cameras are
pointing and a couple of people might
have suspected but some of them
it's very interesting how they do it
because I always wondered how they do it
and they film at the bar for 24 hours at
least cameras are just going constantly
some customers are pissed like I just
want to drag around these goddamn camera
a lot of customers were annoyed yeah
like they have all the lights up they've
all they have cameramen in there uh-huh
and they just stay there for like two
days before Taffer walks in and they
tell all the bars we don't know if we're
gonna do the show or not we're gonna
just get some footage here and if it
works it works and if it doesn't it
doesn't and their theory is and it's
obviously worked is that you leave the
cameras in for two sometimes three days
and after the first however many hours
people start acting like themselves in
front of the camera and that's when you
can start right yeah position like
secret cams in the in the kitchen
they have cams in the bar they've
cameraman walking around and you do
forget about them I guess you get used
to it very quickly like you just forget
the cameras are there I mean they're
just regular people if they have to be
aware of it but then you just start
doing your [ __ ] like I'm just serving
drinks people just drinking those
cigarettes were the worst part of that
place it was a smoking bar I'm not used
to being in place with cigarettes yeah
yeah that's been young time but they go
like like when you go in when Jim and I
went in and we just went up to the bar
to order like it didn't feel like a TV
show it felt like it was being filmed
right but it didn't feel choreographed
well you know that we had to order B we
had to get a certain amount of food just
to see the way it was prepared on a
monitor and in it like they're in a van
and there's cameras in there and I
didn't want to but we get there we get
there and we talk to the producers like
literally right before we went in wien
told them that we don't drink yeah we
figured that which I would have canceled
the airfare oh yeah we wanted to do the
show because we like to show so much in
Tampa and Tampa is like you know how if
you get a free trip damn sure you know
so when we got there we were like they
were like okay here's some options you
could order like you know some of the
stuff we were thinking you know just do
whatever you want but here's what we're
thinking and Jim goes I'm sober yeah I
don't drink like he's like no I've been
sober since I'm 18 like I'm in recovery
and like the producers it's just like
okay like it really threw them for a
loop and they got on their earpiece like
what are we gonna do here bah bah bah
they're trying to figure out the next
plan and they looked at me and they're
like but you drink right and I went yeah
Wow this is your first drawer sign ever
have you ever had to drink of alcohol
yeah why drink at Opie's wedding I drink
beer out of a shoe okay because I guess
it was a tradition but other than that
no oh except guy fieri squirt of vodka
in my mouth that's right I remember how
mad you are yeah that piece of [ __ ]
tastes better when it's not from shoe
well yeah that's why now it's gonna be
my test yeah and so but I was like yeah
[ __ ] what get some brews right right
apparently I might have pronounced the
name of the beer incorrectly wasn't I
let my it was my towel and they edited
me because I asked for a virgin Bloody
Mary but it doesn't sound like I said no
just as Bloody Mary I actually had like
a comment somebody left me a comment on
Instagram going like way to go you
enabling [ __ ] you let your co-host
drink for the first time since he was 18
that's my killing was the guy seriously
seems really himself I just responded to
him you're a [ __ ] idiot television
show you idiots but it was like I was
struck when I was there by how not fake
it was like when when Taffer actually
walked in yeah and the thing just
started is no rehearsal it's just
happening I was like whoa like this is
and people are legit pissed like it's
real taffer's legit doing like they
really didn't expect things to happen
people you could see it in their favor
they're furious at us for being there
they thought we were [ __ ] on their
local bar yeah yeah the customers were
not in on it like they were it was
legitimately inconvenience to them they
were irritated it is real I mean as far
as what he's doing there yeah it's
Israel was it already successful I mean
do you need to rescue and it was or not
was not doing that well the food the
food there's problems with it was a
smoking place I guess they weren't
making the money they wanted to me yeah
it's not anymore right they were not
doing well how intimidating is he
because I see him come in and it gets in
people's faces like bar owners like yeah
yeah he does it so much like I can't
believe the balls on this guy that he's
not afraid of getting hit yeah he walks
in and he does it so much like there was
stuff I saw that didn't make the show
like him just yelling at people going
like Vicki just meets him for the first
time and he starts yelling at the
bartender it wasn't even on the show he
takes control immediately and there's
something about his energy and you do
know that he knows what he's doing so
that's one up he's uh he's the host and
his job is to fix this so automatically
he's in the position of power because
you know why he's there and you
volunteered for it but he really is
[ __ ] uh he just takes over at people
just like they let him be the boss he's
very very uh he's very bossy energy very
controlling energy did the staff
volunteer do they not want to lose their
jobs I don't know I'm not sure what do
you mean did they say well you can't
work these hours if you don't want to
you're not okay with the cameras being
there I mean they tell the staff like
they're all aware so you know I don't
know for sure for sure I mean but they
know they know what they're getting into
cuz some of the staff you watch those
shows you like whoa that is the biggest
jackass I've ever met in my life it's
always like one of those Flair
bartenders and he's got like you know
like a mohawk and like I think a part
that wasn't on the show was I was toward
early get my dick sucked
yeah then leave that in yeah just this
is the hottest chick you ever saw man
got out of the barn she was like holy
[ __ ] Jim Norton get me suck yeah I guess
that was like that's why I normally
don't drink that's why I go to Tampa
though yeah but like guys
I ordered the I ordered some sandwich or
whatever and do a Reuben I think so
greasy [ __ ] Reuben yeah
delicious I talked to the I took to the
bartender he I was like hey I ordered
this and he was like oh I don't like it
then second what he was like yeah I mean
he's like I guess a lot of people order
it but I don't like it let me go show
you order something else and he goes no
people like it and so when Taffer came
in with the owner like 15 minutes later
he was like what'd you order and I was
like oh this is so and so the bartender
told me he didn't like it ratted him out
and then he calls there was a bartender
he starts yelling at him but there was
so much yelling it didn't even make
final cut and he's going here so he's
just picking the food up and handle
like it's he literally it was the way
somebody would peel [ __ ] off their shoe
so he was handling the food he was so
disgusted and he was right he was the
food was awful
you want to watch some of this I hate it
but I will it's only like three minutes
that's my show and I'm so excited to see
you guys on you know what part I'm
talking about right the way the show
works is I haven't watched it did
there's there's there's hidden cameras
or there's cameras in the bar taffer's
not in yeah Taffer sends in Jim and
myself we sit at the bar and we order
our food and we order our drinks and
whatnot
while we're ordering food Taffer and his
chef and his bartender mixologist are
sitting man you know in a truck around
back so they don't know that the truck
is there we didn't never saw the truck
but the truck is around back and they're
watching live on a monitor so they can
comment on what's going on with Jim and
myself and then when Taffer feels right
he get it I'm gonna go in there this has
to stop
and he gets out of the van and he walks
in to the bar and then the show starts
that's it and they film us but we do
like even you did you cheat certain
things and our walk-in was shot after so
after we go through this whole thing and
they have to film us walking in did you
like one or two walkins and the [ __ ]
people hated us by then they knew we're
a part of the show and they saw the guy
getting yelled out of the back and they
were [ __ ] they were heckling us one
woman was head we were doing like these
two camera confessionals after woman was
heckling us leaving it's our [ __ ] bar
oh they were so it was so awkward
luckily like we've watched the show so
we know when our part is done yeah
because nobody told us our part was done
we just sat there and we like kind of
ate our food and then Taffer came in and
we told to have for how disgusting
everything was and how awful a bartender
wasn't I mean the stuff was stale right
well no there was Jim's issue it just
didn't taste
well like Tavor comes in everybody
realizes you know the jig is up like
these guys are not here to enjoy our bar
yeah celebrity is not actually here for
no reason
yeah yeah
it felt like the salsa commercial where
everybody goes New York City piss I love
the idea of heckling someone that's
trying to make your bar better right
stop trying to fix this one but we
wanted to be bad I like it the way it is
that was what it was I mean it was just
[ __ ] gross I can't eat when people
are smoking like I'm not used to people
for smoke it's disgusting yeah Taffer
but Taffer leaves with the owner and Jim
and I are just sitting there after dicks
like we're just sitting there after all
this and then you just stuck and they
just let you have to leave and I was
like and I was like I just looked at Jim
I was like dude let's get out of here
this is not good everybody's looking at
us yeah you know so we just put money
down on the table to pay for everything
and just walked out but then like an
hour later we're just hanging out in the
production room or whatever which is a
store right next door cuz it's in a
strip mall and like an hour later we
have to film the walk-ins like Jim said
so we walked back into the bar and as
soon as we walked into the bar oh there
they are again to [ __ ] on our bar when I
walk into a comedy club and we were in
the we're in the parking lot doing
interviews that they didn't even use
which I thought were the funniest things
that we did because we're talking about
the good things and the bad things in
the bar and like at one point Jim goes
the clientele was not good clientele was
some of the worst I've ever seen and
there's a woman who's sitting on a bench
like way far away from us she's just on
a bench as we're filming going to please
my analysis of the shape she might just
always sit on that bench and shout that
camera crews there but I I had so much
fun doing it me too I thought it was so
funny when they got pissed at us
I enjoyed the gig it was it was fun to
be down there just doing something that
I would normally not do it again
it was amazing though watching how
pissed people get because once it all
got started people started fighting with
each other one person left the bar like
it was real it was legit it's a
fascinating show it's yeah I'm like so
curious when you guessed it it's great
do you want to ask questions as we go
watchable a feather yeah why'd you guys
are here for this GM aren't you glad
that we have more comedians in the
studio to watch us on bar rescue
yeah the only the only time I saw this
was in a comedy club but they did that
stand up Scott
do you see that oh I seen that one you
did all played that Club and the owner
was quite a character and then yeah and
then they did the redemption you guys
might be brought back for the redemption
of how oh I hope so
if there is one well love this if you
want a spoiler nope I don't
well when I can play the whole episode
no I was I still want to find out the
end you tell me at the end okay I'll
tell you at the end let's start we're
just gonna do our stuff so let's start
with clip number two Troy and we're
start and stop this a lot I hate the way
my shirt blouse is that when I walk in
you've already seen it yeah I've seen
that I hate the way my shirt is my I
hate watching myself walk so there's
there's Jim and I and our Tampa do you
people did pick up on the fact they're
like Sam you're [ __ ] Tampa Florida
you need a flannel shirt and a leather
jacket and Tampa I noticed that again
that's whether we were miked it's August
it's a cool of 95 yeah I just trying to
look cool yeah you know I thought you
know fashion not function exactly I
think it was all sort of two Mikus
though right we did we did have a
wireless yeah but I need to wear a
leather jacket a flannel shirt
you didn't operation though exactly you
think I look cool Troy I think you look
though next man I appreciate that that's
what I was going out of our place fool
so for recon I wanted to bring in some
friends of mine no bars I mean this is
just I want to bring in some friends of
mine who know John they weren't
available for airfare
oh nice matching purple t-shirts -
that's true it wasn't intentional but
you're right I have been of bars okay I
know yeah I know bars I go to bars
sometimes use the washroom
right subir you know I went to two bars
while I was in Tampa over the weekend oh
really and I could tell one the club
soda one was flatter than at the other
so yes exactly
Troy why don't we rewind a little bit
yeah so for recon I wanted to bring in
some friends of mine
no bars Jim and Sam do two of the
biggest stars in Sirius Radio these guys
have millions of followers yeah baby
millions although you know last names
wouldn't hurt that would have been
helpful Jim and Sam I'm serious
but look at my head on camera awful I
think it looks good doesn't the first
shot you guys look great you both you do
look like people that go to bars for
frequent we do we look like experts all
mostly these guys drink look at us just
both hunched over the bar like I just a
couple of guys that's what we do when we
cuddle afterwards yeah yeah at the local
watering hole yeah some people were
curious where John got the information
that we have millions of people who
listen to our show I informed him of
that yeah that would be us although this
is how [ __ ] stupid I am this I'm
guessing they cut this out they did and
we've been we've been talking about this
since we did it we've never actually
told this Jon Taffer was talking to us
we're saying that when they're talking
to the woman and he goes so I knew guys
are on serious say how many people do
you have listening and I'm like well
actually they don't tell us because you
know they don't want to give the house I
gave him a real answer and sounds like
just millions millions over with the
lady and she's so dumb he's like these
are my friends Jim and Sam they have one
of the most popular shows how many
people listen to your show and that's
where Jim goes they don't tell the truth
I don't yeah but I leaned over to him
and I said there's 30 million
subscribers and we're the number one
show in the platform yeah you know yeah
that was that was where Sam is [ __ ]
WWE thinking came into play we're
selling baby we're salad just look at
how many people are criticizing Joe and
Phil on Instagram right now yeah yeah I
mean where I go we're number one show
Howard was like Howard Stern's like
counting I was like no I don't know I
haven't seen the numbers yeah pretty
sure were two and then sways behind him
yeah it goes Jim and Sam Howard sway yep
and then I don't know anymore yeah I
don't know dan Rather who else has a
show here no this is Dan Rather show
they don't joke is over for him in here
at five browserand I enjoy it we had him
on once I'd love to interview him again
he's a really interesting guy he is the
first one to see this approver film Wow
that's a baby I'm supportive dan Rather
trivia yep let's go back to it guys
reckon Bloody Mary
okay I found out later that's not the
name of that beer and Hammer Zack amber
Bock that's how you would pronounce what
did you call it
amber babbling like this you have a
amber back amber man that's right in
Canada you see me shrug it when I said
it - that's acting that they'll be like
offering on Millay I don't know that
beer why did you pick and obscure oh did
they suggested that was one of the ones
you could pick and I was going like this
in my head amber Jack I was going in my
head as like amber back in back then use
like what do you want house like I don't
know amber back keeper winding Troy yeah
yeah it when we guys are good Bloody
Mary that works great with the size of
that glass for a Bloody Mary that's
gonna hold about two and a half ounces
of Bloody Mary Mix typically that would
be in a taller glass
this is Bernie my throat is awful no it
was a beer I was just being truthful
yeah it's burning your throat it hurt my
throat yeah I like that he when I said
I'll have a amber back and he looked at
me funny you know I was like oh I wonder
if he knows that like I shouldn't be
ordering that but now that people told
me I think it was probably because he
was thinking that's not how that word
sound like the kid and can't hardly wait
right now oh yeah nice to rub it off
with your finger I didn't know he did
that
[Music]
by the way nice sip dick why go look at
that [ __ ] sip I mean Elizabeth sip
that's me having a uh having a beer and
unwinding most people's first beer isn't
televised what is dainty it's a swig of
beer for the working man and regularly
don't say sips a swig yeah see see Sam
take a nice swing up here I'm a chugger
look at this oh my god you touched your
lips to it if I did that it wouldn't
been a relapse that's how you call this
amber back door ring like that's my line
from the show what slam a few drinks in
then everything's fine and it's like I
knew when I was saying it I'm being
critical of the bar they're gonna leave
that in yeah yeah yeah side of the bar
oblivious to the fact that her business
is going down the tubes right before her
eyes and she doesn't even know it he
only get a classic burger
see the food order is in I'm gonna time
this that's just my read typical bar
order I get a Reuben and a beef on weck
that's people are like well the leaf is
the one they all said was very good you
chicken fingers yeah the beef on weck
was the one that was like theirs that
was that was the crowd favorite
what's a wek I don't know it's like a
like I think it's like a wedge I don't
know what it is but I was like that was
the house specialty and that's the one
that the bartender was like I don't like
it oh really it was like oh yeah
critical of the [ __ ] that the house
specialty the beef on weck a beef on
weck it's a sandwich primarily found in
western New York State not Tampa what
Travis I like Jim's furrowed brow and he
was thinking about how we want I know
considering it yeah I mean I typically
will go with a well let's go back and
look at that yeah I would like to see
what Jim where he's considering were you
acting no I was actually considering
landing
maybe a little I was in sixth I knew
what I was in I thought you know that
right cuz you probably thought about it
beforehand but you're portraying
somebody who's just walked into a bar
what would my is what Jim was thinking
what my character order you know before
arrives and she doesn't even know it
carefully like is that possible
hmm yeah do medium and this is my
character casually ordering things I was
very nervous because I don't order a lot
of this stuff very often so I was afraid
I was doing it wrong so I wanted to come
across as casual as possible so the food
you like ah you must order that all that
was the camera was a little closer to
you how long this takes
okay here we go those are dogging
walking bags the pooper-scooper bags it
looks that way
but there's certainly not foodservice
bags should the sauerkraut look like a
hash brown
so obviously that brown is what was
cooked on there a hundred times before
you got all kinds of stuff in that salad
crowd aside man I want your food and
then I was hungry how long does the food
usually a very fair question an
establishment you don't be not just
paying for food you're paying for
service when it's medium they brought us
in and they just they just were like we
just need them we're gonna use the lines
where they just do like the facts we
need them figuring out how long the
food's gonna take so they took the gym
line where he goes how long does the
food take if it was a lot of we talked
for a little bit and criticized it but
you know we had a back and forth with
yeah with the customers number all the
other customers because we got the other
customers to [ __ ] on the bar oh yeah one
guy was like really unhappy yeah
remember what one guys almost some of
the fighting yeah these two guys got in
a fight and like one of them walked out
no I'm not sitting here with this
drinking with you yeah it's awesome
that's what you want to see had someone
just take a mug and [ __ ] violent
murder like an old lake old lady a
concerned grandma mom these are just
little clips I mean the editing show my
stomach is rumbling I'm sure the food
would be not even paying attention to
you and you say that wasn't asking
couldn't look like a less funny person
to go stuff
yeah they bring everything into go boxes
because at a smoking bar you're not
allowed to serve food so their
workaround is the kitchen is actually in
a different is in the building next door
so they have to walk out of the bar to
the kitchen next door that's different
billing have to go outside and into the
next door then they cook the food then
they have to put the food into
boxes so technically you're ordering
food from the restaurant next door and
the smart action and so everything but
everything has to be eaten in these
to-go boxes so we ordered like four or
five things yeah not on our dime we're
gonna try everything and so we just had
a pile of like styrofoam to-go boxes in
front of us the smoking was making me
sick
although what they say is gross with it
with the clientele at the bar said is
nobody orders the food here they said we
just buy McDonald's and then we would
just bring the meat down let you bring
your own food in yeah you guys you know
yeah you have to be able to technically
if you want to get if you want to use
this loophole yeah it's not like you can
say well we only allow food from that
restaurant like okay well I'm bringing
Wendy's net yeah well that's always
gonna be good then yeah you're getting
Joe yeah you made a good point thank you
very much the footage shows I did ask
yeah yeah no no the original us Remini
oh yes Familia now I really contemplated
what I want yeah she's like no you asked
well done Joe let's go to the team we
fail you right 28 minutes to get the
food it's either undercooked overcooked
not seasoned properly but it's not right
so they're not taking care of anything
but yet Doreen's life is going down a
fricking drain right now and none of
them are doing anything about it Vic
until now I'm gonna go in well get them
doing something about it I wonder how
many take that that is just play a
couple of those he makes it sound like
he's going off to war like you guys
baiting is like a guy is punching into a
stroller
[Laughter]
all right you want to see him going in
and and having us let Dory know yeah
where things went awry and you feel bad
for her she seems so nice she she was
sitting there like literally this lady
is she's not faking when she came over
to us her eyes were wild up with tears
she was like quivering oh no I guess
later I realized you meet a celebrity
highly influential people who have
between 30 million and they won't tell
us how many listen yes between 0 and 30
million too many to count and and yeah
and she's sitting there like shaking
like I go with this sandwich was super
Gracie look at my hands and she's like
oh no oh yeah it was tough it was tough
looking at Doreen I was like wait a
minute because I was sitting there going
like ah [ __ ] all over everything and
then I looked at this woman and I was
like yeah oh no this is real life yes
this lady's lies really her bar this is
her place and cares about it yeah I mean
I think I'm still gonna [ __ ] all over
everything but still legitimately was
shitty it was easy you didn't have to
lie about it they did get the orders
wrong it did take too long the food
wasn't good no they didn't even show we
also ordered wings and the wings were
like it tastes like they were microwaved
and they were just sitting in a puddle
of sauce yeah we ordered a lot of
disgusting
[Music]
and I didn't even see him by the way
walk in the door and they just try to
keep up behind us
yeah we didn't know he was there until
Taffer and this lady walks over and
we're like oh my god this is happening
and then they got pissed big trouble
aren't you
I want you to need a couple of friends
of mine okay Jim and Sam a dear friends
of mine sure have one of the biggest
shows on Sirius radio sure okay that's
the editing mark where they took out
Jim's honest answer I know selling gas I
can't help it honesty's the best policy
why was she not crying after she found
out yeah I mean don't you like have to
pitch things and why do you think I
don't have any show I have a script that
is legitimately funny but I can't pitch
it woman terrible salesperson we're
worried you may have a limited audience
no that's a good point when I used to
sell when I was a kid in the USA Today
was first a newspaper
I was probably till 12 and I one day I
some guy hired us to sell you got a
dollar for every subscription you could
sell and I would go door-to-door trying
to sell the USA Today and I would my
pitch was high you don't want to buy a
paper - yeah and same when you ask girls
out yeah oh yeah you don't want to go
out with me dude yes there's always a
naked and what is the answer always um
no I had a guy last night I was at the
seller and we were talking and he was
very nice and he goes you don't do a
selfie do you and I was I almost said
nah but because because he led me into
it it was really weird and I thought of
that after he left I was like yeah of
course man and we but my instinct was to
go no just because he said you don't
want like this suggestion that I didn't
want to yet you realized you realize it
you're making it easy to say no but I
didn't want to say no I don't mind
taking a selfie right it wasn't like
[ __ ] you almost let me off the hook he
was just like you don't want to take one
and he was like almost in an effort to
agree with
person right you're almost being polite
but yeah yeah you're right I took one
but you gotta sell it better you've
liked this selfie is gonna be so awesome
you're gonna come yeah but was the other
point now yeah that was that was at the
moment John probably goes I quit how did
Jim get to where he's at I mean
you sell tickets for a living yeah at
the end of the day why about ticket
counts I don't talk about I don't lie I
know yeah they're great they're great
they're nothing up I don't go in and
pretend it's sold out it's not I guess
that's how you know you're really funny
because if you weren't you wouldn't
convince people to go to your comic you
wouldn't be able to convince people to
go to your comedy and that's terrible
convince her hardly anyone goes to mine
right and that well that's how you know
you're funny I just figure I'm only a
conduit for the gift it channels through
you you were chosen you know that's I
don't want to say by the way I hate when
people compliment someone you ever see
someone they get a compliment like yeah
you're really funny and they do the
[ __ ] the hands class yeah thank you
you know who does that every single time
hot dog no he doesn't the mysterious hot
dog he always does that this is his
thing you fake bow two hands just say
thanks you [ __ ] socially awkward
idiots he does it every time every
single it doesn't have to be a
life-altering moment no I open the door
like I hold the door open for him and he
just goes huh hmm he doesn't he just
kind of goes I thank you it doesn't feel
like enough for them so they want to
show reverence it's also but I think
it's people who emotionally I just have
trouble and then living through emojis
the emoji is depends exactly it's easier
to do this than to actually express
gratitude but also it's a fake
spirituality yeah it is namaste shut up
yeah I yell at him every time he does it
yeah he's so stupid
I put in an egg
I'm like you don't want me to thank you
you know what you want yeah you're not
welcome are you let's just go better day
yeah all right let's see the salesman
says yeah to know what you felt coming
here why didn't you eat this it just
didn't taste fresh great slider subway
guy it did really I had I hated to tell
Doreen this right right well she was
very nice she see I'm getting a vibe
from her that's very nice yeah I felt
bad for her cause she was like you know
it's easy when you're watching some on
TV to your [ __ ] but when they come
over and you can see like she was
shaking you're upset you know she
genuinely care nicely yes she's a nice
lady that's the thing about Jim like he
will at this point in his life put those
feelings over a TV show like you're like
I'm doing a TV show here but this lady
is hurting I can't like yeah and
unfortunately for her and at my position
in life I go like I get it you're upset
lady but we got to make some TV here
let's go this thing [ __ ] sucks yeah I
just had to be gentle yeah I think
that's the way I would have played it
gentle yeah yeah I would have felt bad
for but then again back your head you're
like well you eat here and her answer
I'm there's no way she's like oh yeah I
have that filthy Ruben every day no this
was literally the moment did I threw the
bartender under the bus I just made it
even worse like yeah the bartender told
me the sandwich wasn't good and I said
he tried to sell me kiddie porn I didn't
hear it it's called a yes and I made um
they cut the part where you bought it -
okay see this this is pretty bad
I watched him make this the entire
sandwich John puts his hands all in it
you can make any sandwich look gross
though if you like scoop it up for me
sure in a minute you know you can make
PA any sounds looks disgusting you put
your fingers in it but I said as I was
giving it to her this is pretty bad
you know that way you know it's bits bad
yeah yeah you did you indicated yeah
that's the way usually works
my god I'm angry
is a complete mess to the fact of the
matter is you guys came to you trying to
get a beer that would work you try to
get a burger you try to get a Reuben
sandwich nothing work this cannot happen
okay let's go [ __ ] see they cut my line
there was your like that's not I was
afraid it was poor Tori she's Dori
important Doreen and do you see them
walking away from us you see how we're
still sitting there in there yeah that's
not like a set up shot where then they
come and they're like okay we need to do
the walkway left us there they left us
if we didn't get up we'd still be
sitting there with mics they just left
us there and everybody's just staring at
us and the people who we were making
friends with some other people at the
bar I'm talking about local stuff and
they felt Larry felt lied to I bet they
thought the whole thing was just a rumor
to put on to make them look foolish
you've never had an amber back before we
told him we were just down there at
Seward to visit the Epstein mentioned
but yeah that was that was that's it
that's what solidified us as bar experts
to guys you know bars it's right yeah
and then fresh
is that the end isn't more that's it
then what about when the lady called you
a [ __ ] in the parking lot and you
don't show that oh that's a bummer yeah
they didn't use that I mean they just
let the clientele be fear I think they
don't want it to seem like the people at
the bar were mad at us yeah because they
don't want people at home to be like oh
there's all these people that like this
bar Yeah right good point you know let
me see how John shows the updated bar we
don't have to watch the whole thing oh
you want to see how he changed it she
calls out customers what does he make
one little observation for the bar sure
it's a buffalo themed turnit bar it is
yeah hello city bar he's from Buffalo
New York right western New York is where
they had that what's it called the beef
whack the way all right
I love Buffalo when I was a kid we would
go like because I grew up near there I
would go to Buffalo all the time I kind
of a boring childhood but yeah always
ever said those words in a row
I love Buffalo it seems like an odd
theme for right like if you're gonna
pick any city nobody in Tampa knows
anything about Buffalo yeah you're right
it was like a wing specialty I could see
it knocked Buffalo away they were
terrible they were horrible yeah yeah
what inspired Doreen to from bro
I didn't make the show I was a spy but I
feel like that would be a question you
won't know is it still a Buffalo themed
restaurant we don't know I've never seen
this okay was her dad Oh her dad her dad
started the boys from Buffalo came down
and it was a Buffalo themed somebody
watched your boys on bar rescue of
course I did I want to see her calling
out customers did you think it was funny
yeah I was a little disappointed that
you guys weren't in there enough hoping
you guys were going to come back when
they redid it and no way I could get on
a plane and left they yeah they think I
overdid it a little bit I faked a heart
attack how long did it take to actually
do it it is a legit three days oh really
oh yeah it takes three days so the the
next or maybe it's four days because the
next night they were gonna do the stress
test where they just pile a whole bunch
of people in there and they watch the
bar function normally
and then I think after the stress test
they take 48 hours I think to redo it
wow that's pretty impressive because
they do some major changes yes yeah yes
let's see we could see the changes
you're calling our customers Oh
how does she call them out and I need to
see you take control of this bar and
show some reason the same sweater so I
think this is the same night maybe we
will recognize some of the customers I
hope so control of a business now I want
to see if she gets angry and aggressive
and takes control of her staff this is
not do you know why i sat there that
long with a beer like that you don't
drink
mmm I didn't tell him that man that bar
expert dabbed this to his lips Bryce got
a better drink of vinegar on the cross
we were becoming friends of that
bartender we really [ __ ] him huh you
[ __ ] literally just dabbed your
little lips on it I know I did yeah and
then I ratted him out hey dude yeah I
really I really played that that poor
bartender for a fool it was a terrible
tattoo on his forearms well that's just
the ink exploded it's very Tampa Tampa
it looks like a like a bed frame I would
have she was a Dorian say everyone Ozzie
in 1985 he gets angry and aggressive and
takes control of her staff he sat here
for a half an hour with the beer like
that you should offer him something else
to drink and take in this and dump it
I am freakin angry that they stole 92
thousand dollars worth of liquor from me
and this year my bartenders have given
away ninety two thousand dollars worth
of my liver
that lady hated us oh she's the one that
yelled at us he's the one who yelled at
a chalet ma'am yeah
when did where it was that where does
she yell at you guys right parking lot
first she yelled at us in the bar when
we were walking through the walk past
one that yelled at us we walked in the
water
oh yeah back and then after this I think
that she must get it she's store she
stormed out look at this guy on the left
that's every other guy in Mississippi
Burning
[Laughter]
she this lady in the flowered blouse
hated Jim Norton and Samba have a lot of
hate I love her yeah I do dude she drank
a lot that $92,000 Jim and I were like
feverishly giggling had everybody
yelling at us like I really thought she
might get in try to get into a physical
altercation
[Applause]
whatsoever not oh yeah the caller she's
pissed especially the local watering
hole Jerry Sandusky's having a beer this
literally looks like they did a casting
roundup and said we need look we need 20
of the ugliest human beings in the
country she wouldn't like to hear that
no she's actually the hottest one there
I love her she's fiery she is fiery yeah
it is she would have fought us you know
mad she'd get it my dick if it didn't
work do you think it would looks like
Tampa clientele oh it was see all this
stuff is legit like every ounce of what
happened there that was all for real so
where were you guys at this point we
that we had laughing but I remember when
this was happening we were there like in
that so it was in this strip mall
it was the bar and the next door was the
restaurant where the kitchen for the bar
was yeah and the next door to that was
this vacant store mm-hmm did they put
blackout windows over and that was the
quote-unquote production office okay so
we would we were either in the
production office or we were kind of
just hanging out outside on the sidewalk
just you there's a lot of waiting
because Taffer kind of calls it on the
field you know what I mean he just lets
it happen and figures out what he's
gonna do
so we waited around for a while but
while we were waiting is when that
altercation happened I didn't realize I
didn't realize there's between her and
Doreen okay I didn't know that either
yeah let's go to John up shows the
updated bar oh do you want to see chef
Bob getting yelled at for the sauerkraut
yeah anything because yeah let's go to
clip 5 because that was my sauerkraut
that I was talking about how yummy so
yeah I know I almost did but I correct
myself
not anymore pointing out you know really
it just didn't taste fresh you [ __ ]
dark bag scumbag hey what's your name
they call me Bob how long have you
worked here I'll be your name exactly
for roughly ten years so you work for
Frank as well yes sir I watched a
sauerkraut sandwich get made last night
sauerkraut shouldn't be browned like
hashbrowns and the sandwich done is so
goddamn moist although it falls apart in
a customer's hand talk about us Jim
where the customers you were the
customer and he said it just didn't
taste fresh did you look more Tampa than
this dude he probably he's really
playing as long fingernails and a
10-inch dick skinny white guy with a
ponytail forget of these all [ __ ] Groban
queen sandwich it was not all that bad
yeah it isn't all that bad is that
acceptable to you
no it's not all that good either which
suck why would you search something you
know sucks because it doesn't suck did
it suck it was overcooked yeah
Bob is [ __ ] he's really just yelling
at this guy who probably did six years
totally you know Bob did six years for a
vehicular homicide sir I can't I can't
respond to you in that tone yeah yes sir
I'm Aryan tattoos that's why I love
Taffer
cuz he doesn't just go in and yell at
weak Pino he doesn't he'll yell at
everybody he doesn't care also he's
dressed like the hamburger
there's a bomb in it really is purple
yeah are you saying jon taffer in
another life could have played the
grimace yeah yeah I don't even know if
he hadn't but yeah I'm just saying I'm
not I'm not sure I respect his taste are
you I had my inventory touch around
sculptural hospitality come in here and
weigh every liquor bottle no no we then
ran this weekend we then weighed
everything a second time at the end of
the weekend we consumed sixty five
hundred ninety-eight dollars worth of
product we actually sold forty seven
hundred and thirteen dollars this
weekend in just two days we burned
eighteen hundred and eighty five dollars
it's math and two nights when I
annualized that number it's ninety two
thousand dollars a year crazy giving
away a lot of stuff yeah they don't know
what they're doing yeah going to see the
new bar yeah okay because the sign was
even [ __ ] up wasn't it yeah that's not
yet a lettering was off I think it I
think the word bar was not lit yeah yeah
yeah
oh it's stocked up no it's it's lit now
the still missing [ __ ] the girls cry who
she like her daughter she's hot she's
hot
whose daughters Doreen's daughters oh
she's got a man check her finger go back
yeah sign I wouldn't touch but I added
BCBG to all the windows what color to
the street so you see it I wanted people
to see how big it is look at all those
red windows I wanted to put in
call-to-actions music games hot
sandwiches I got t-squared custom signs
to work on this all night wanting to get
this done yeah oh yeah Dori would love
me as a son-in-law would ya is it fresh
enough if you're running joke in the
family medium I actually believe it's
her niece not her daughter even better
she's beautiful
yeah she's a lovely lady yeah I should
have taken her out didn't have the
option man yeah only one thing left is
there yeah you ready to see it
okay let's see it okay
looks a lot more modern more it looks
much nicer bit purple lighting yeah a
little metallic flair did a lot of stuff
that's Buffalo purple Bob is still
around and there's a portrait to her dad
oh that's nice
she's crying again this one has not shy
and here's a giant box of tissues for
durian um the nice is cute yeah she's
nice people now here's the thing good
for them it's not the end ah
that's all they still had to smoke
though it was a smoking bars
I know but you'd hope they go
non-smoking um the thing that we found
out at the end of all this durian sold
the bar
oh she sold it she sold it okay and it
has since closed oh really
oh maybe they that's what I was informed
is that right Travis is that information
that you received yes right why to the
old way of making sauerkraut sandwiches
they offered her half a million for it
who did he hired somebody to offer the
for the business they could buy for half
a million or she could keep it mm-hmm
she uh she went for the half yeah and
then yeah apparently uh Travis said that
he is family around the area and they go
oh I know that bar closed which is why I
mean this all February's when this all
happened really so it's been sold and
closed yeah but the thing is they or
they offer a half a million for it and I
wonder if the building is owned or no
they just recently seen the building man
I'm what am i a real estate agent as
well be question is that because why
would you just sell it and and close the
bar yeah you didn't make the money or
you only wanted it for the real estate
or maybe they want to flip it and do
something totally different yeah a lot
of debt with it really I'm crazy amount
of debt I wonder if they bought out the
debt and then they were like this isn't
happening
yeah I think there's a clip here well
Denise Jon told ya yeah we're sure
let's talk to her let's talk to Doreen's
nice about this you watch the
walkthrough yeah yeah they talk about
some of the bar Oh talks about uh well
which is first I mean the walkthroughs
en we just saw the end already yeah we
saw the reveal Hey so it's over I want
to see the nice again yep I walk through
the back of the bar I like this dress
test [ __ ] shirt and tie
the minute John was on the plane that
shirt looks really different I hate that
they're all having fun
toasting I hate when people toast row
Taffer came to town and made everybody
happy that's the way the show works
except the best episodes are the ones
where he walks out without fixing yeah
those are the [ __ ] amazing would be
seeming Buffalo buffalo City Bar City
yep yeah be City baby
hopefully you don't read it the other
way in BBC I think it's a play on CBGB
yeah not bb's more the Gee Bee Gee Bee
Gees no the first BBC
for you good I didn't think British
Broadcasting Corporation no but was just
bombing at this point yeah you know we
can do isn't freeing sometimes just when
you a good bomb sometimes is really
cleansing like you know I got that out
of my system
you just wake you up it is its in its
invigorating it's it's a really weird
thing I'm alive yeah when you're bombing
in front of people you do feel so alive
when you come offstage it's like a cold
it's like a Polar Bear Swim it's amazing
yeah that's amazing yeah it can be
really it sucks when it happens for a
long period of time like I haven't
bothered the headline set when I've had
some not your crowd yeah like that one
should have worked
yeah three minutes you like huh my a is
getting a deal right yeah I got a long
time to go I know is there like a joke
like early on that you're like if this
one didn't work it's gonna be a long
night
there are certain times you open a
certain way but you know you can go to
this and go to that to take the crowd do
exactly what you want them to do right
so in when the little thing your
experiment with doesn't work and you
ought to go to this or you look down you
realize you've done like 20 minutes of
material and you're at like eight
minutes and you gotta start playing with
the crowd usually you can get them but
by talking to the crowd and segue into a
bit and they think you're just making it
but yeah that's the [ __ ] when you're
grabbing for something you know work so
yeah but that's one of your [ __ ]
alright this is what I'm gonna I'm gonna
get a big laugh here I know that this is
yeah yeah it gets a tentative Laura
dinner oh yeah yeah it's brutal it's
awesome hate it we should we should
break yeah I'm glad you guys were here
for I'm going to be see a BCBG it's open
oh it is open Travis is dumb Travis your
family is dumb dumb whichever way your
mom went that's the way everybody should
have gone he's not the only one with a
brain in her
information they did one more gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM f
[Music]